what's up Tiger belly crew first off the
last podcast with Adam Ray was hilarious
almost [ __ ] at work anyways I was
adopted I was adopted from Seoul and
fresh out of the oven and I was flown to
California where I grew up outside of
Fresno I don't have any info on my birth
parents other than my mom's name and the
district I was born in I've been getting
these strong urges the past couple years
to try and find her and I've decided
that when the time's right I'll move
there for a couple years I got one big
problem though I'd be leaving everything
behind I guess you could say I got
everything I need here
family friends girlfriend desk job but
honestly I'd give that all up just to
find my birth mom and learn about more
learn more about my country hell I even
wash dishes in some alley if that's what
it takes to survive oh my god I've only
had a few people tell me about this idea
and they all say this won't do anything
for my future or career I know you
probably had to make huge life changes
so my question is how do you deal with
all the push back and keep your goals
right also what kind of friends do you
have if all they think there is in life
is your future career what about your
soul yeah what about the things that
actually like matter that they Dec for
them to say they have their birth
parents with a soul it's gonna take two
years yeah also why would meaning your
birth mother have to be such a drastic
thing like I mean I know I mean I get
that all right
especially you know here's a guy was
adopted probably by white people it's
always the case so that's the assumption
I'm gonna make what do you mean he was
adopted right yeah yeah yeah and white
he had white parents adopted them you're
Asian you grew up in this white house I
could only imagine that your whole life
you're like I mean I love these people
and they love me and I love them like my
parents but you know you you want to
long for your own flesh and where you
came from and you know and you know your
little personality quirks and stuff like
I know where I get when I look at my
brother and he gets rageful I know he
gets that's with my dad it's cute you
know some of my you know loud you know
things that I do in public is for my mom
it's cute and I know where I get it from
I also know in terms of like diseases
like my dad
blood pressure stroke and all those
things you just know want to know what
you're made of and who you are and I
think I get it but I don't think is
gonna take two years yet to live in the
streets like you know I think that to be
that dramatic yeah been a couple of
months why don't you just find her and
then take like a 10-day trip out her to
meet her if she's even open to that cuz
you might open to it it's not to you
know so you also have to prepare
yourself for the fact that that's a
possibility that someone does not want
to meet the son that I know but you know
what it's like if I even if right now
I've imagined me like you know on stage
and some kid that kind of looks like me
closer to me after the show and go
that's when you know you're my dad your
reaction mom let's just say Jennifer
field very specific or you know any of
my or you know whatever whoever yeah
like I remember I had sex with a girl
from Portland and I did it with no
condom
so it says he what's her right and he's
like yeah so I forgot her name let's see
what's on the girl who came to your show
and what try to give you like nipple
tassels as gifts
no no that's weird and so and I said
well doctor any and he's I'd be like oh
[ __ ] I never knew you think I know but
yeah I just wanted to meet you and I'd
be like well you would have lunch I mean
I would want to know what his life was
like you know what you know you know
everything about him I want to know
everything about him and if he doesn't
want to know me or any of that then
that's fine that's his prerogative but
for me I would want to be a part of his
life in some degree like you imagine you
know Julie my niece who was with us for
three months yeah her dad wants nothing
to do with her life can you imagine I
can imagine
great girl it's insane that people do
that but I had the fart oh look yeah I
took imodium to ad that's why so there I
know that [ __ ] free that's why I pulled
it out you know I could put the
strengthen I anyway you know I did a
dude I was on I was just a sidetrack
my second show in San Antonio yeah
Saturday night maybe like 80% of my act
is done and I had a big fart mm-hmm I
just stopped the show ninja hey guys do
you mind if I just fart in the mic to
see what it sounds like and the how
crazy I farted in such a way it was a
two-minute laugh like a little I did it
what that's what it sounded like there
like nine different sounds to it and the
it just caused an eruption of laughter
and I was laughing too and it just was
MIT a minute couple of minutes I mean
anyway you guys I think it's called just
farts no greatest thing you guys have to
let me make sure that's the correct
while you do that yeah it is just
underscore farts and here I'll show it's
just a guy in the dark and recording
supports how do you know it's real
though
he's like just farts his bio is come
check out my farts a hundred percent
real farts vme or farts if you want to
be featured Bob you got to do it this
video clips everyone let me see this one
yeah that was his latest one videos were
just all black it has six hundred
followers I do you find that if it's 600
followers and he's following 4000 people
the only way you could find something
like that is if you actually search the
farts on Instagram I think one of you we
got to find one that mimics yours oh oh
my good one that's great like all these
comedians follow
okay so that's I think one of your
openers I think Craig yeah Craig yeah
yeah so anyway this guy back to this guy
would betray him before he's like I want
to see my I want to see my mom what a
fine I have every right to look and if
she was a decent human being I think
she'd want to meet you
and I think I would go for it but don't
live out there for two years and become
a dishwasher yeah yeah I think there are
ways to reunite without having to give
your entire life away and also if your
friends aren't supportive weird that I
find that to be really weird unless
they're aware of the fact that like
maybe she was like some you know
horrible great crazy person maybe maybe
no no because the puppy baby don't put
puppy on the table the puppy will fall
oh well its bones yeah it'll break its
bones get the puppy any shows for Bobby
no shows
when's your next show Bobby Lee live
[Music]